台灣股市今天重返47000了
5萬點馬上達標嗎
還記得上上個月底
在台灣股市跌破4萬點買1億的男人嗎
就是我 我現在賺到1800萬了
如果你去買個正2
你去買個什麼主動型ETF
我那時候說你可以買主動型ETF
賺更多
中長期不一定要買
但是短期反彈我們賺更多
投資朋友 我還可以賺到3000萬以上
但是我
沒關係 我賺1000多萬就夠了
重點是你要會賺錢
台灣股市還有加上就業數據好
加升息機率增
可是股市為何漲呢
漲的是因為這個原因
黃仁勳認證AGI
就是超級AI
AGI是什麼
台股10萬點不是夢
投資朋友 我要的AI來了
你們都看不懂我看到的未來
沒關係 我告訴你未來來了
這一切的一切我預告在前面
大家好 我是摩爾投顧投資長
郭哲榮分析師
也是全台灣唯一一位100萬粉絲訂閱
不只 現在140幾萬訂閱的分析師
郭哲榮分析師
大家好 我太開心了
今天台灣股市漲775點
是不是看到這個行情想要親親我一下
是不是 投資朋友
大聲的吶喊
是誰在跌破4萬點的時候
像梁靜茹一樣給你勇氣的
就是我
你要唱歌是不是
我還沒那麼快要Cue你
你要唱就唱 來
你幹嘛突然出聲音
你很恐怖 你是鬼喔
我本來想喊投資長
是喔 你是喊投資長
我以為你是要唱勇氣
那你就唱勇氣吧
愛真的需要勇氣
來面對流言蜚語
4萬點的時候一堆人說
AI不會變現
我說那些人根本看不懂未來
我今天告訴大家
我的未來來了
我先跟大家講
因為有些人剛認識我
2020年的時候
我是全台灣第一個講說要開始買口罩
第一個跟你說口罩缺貨
第一個跟你講說疫苗會在1年內發生
也是第一個跟你講
那時候 過幾年後
疫苗要趕快打的男人
有沒有 請回答
第一個喔 那時候一堆醫生嗆我
我是要告訴你
那個時候非專業的
我都可以預測這樣的未來
我告訴你AI的預測太簡單
對我來說太簡單了
好不好 這個跟大家講
唱的好好聽 趕快
等一下就看到
等一下會洗板你就看到
趕快那些粉絲
至少都看我的節目5年了
你就知道我根本非人哉
我告訴你預測實在太簡單了
現在超級AI已經來了
超級AI 我那天跟你講了以後
我又再研究一遍 太恐怖了
台灣股市現在漲是漲超級AI
你不要去管那個
我知道有些人要找我的碴
說哲哲 你不是說
你回去自己看我禮拜五影片好不好
你不是說非農就業數據不能太高
不然會升息
可是現在有一個更大的利多
可是我那時候有講
公布後只要高於預期
會先跌再說
可是我沒有說最後一定會跌
我的結論不一樣
我說是低於預期的話
那個數字越少代表越不景氣
就不會升息
如果比56000低就會從頭漲到尾
可是如果高的話會先跌再說
這個邏輯 文字語法不同
你可以作證
你自己回去看我禮拜五的節目
我跟一般人不一樣
我都講得很清楚啦
來 我們來看一下大家
你看有喔 有沒有看到
大家講有 有沒有看到
這些人都說有 有沒有看到
有喔 有沒有 這個跟大家講
至少有1 20個有沒有看到
都講有
都有講 有沒有看到
1 20個講
疫苗也好 那時候叫你打疫苗
哪有分析師給你預測要打疫苗
哪有分析師跟你講1年內有疫苗
那時候一堆醫生打電話來罵我
有一個醫生打電話來罵我
我不是要嗆醫生
我是要告訴你
我最強的是我的預告能力
超級AI來了
連黃仁勳都這樣講 你看一下
恭喜啦 ChatGPT-6 Astra
從ChatGPT第一個版本到Astra
就是2023年
我第一個公開講
AI會漲3年
漲1年甚至漲3年
那時候我去各大財經台的時候
沒有各大 大概1 2個
跟他們講的時候
他們不相信 你在講什麼東西
AI股會漲1年 太誇張了
I don't care
我不在乎
這也是因為這樣子
後來我也不太上媒體
太累了 我幹嘛跟別人講那些
不一定每個人看得懂
我看得到未來
我在這邊想講什麼就講什麼
我開心
我再講一件事情
你們現在很多人
不論是法律助理也好
一般助理也好 客服人員也好
還有駕駛人員也好
小客車的駕駛人員
你們很快在3到5年內
會被大幅取代
你們要趕快改變工作 真的
我還看了一個台大資工系
寫了一個公開書
他說其實以後真的
有兩種選擇
要嘛就是大家群體而已
每個人少了20%的工作量
要嘛就可能20%的人長期失業
我認同他的講法
我是比較偏向後者
當然他長期失業後
可能會再創造新的行業
可是這種結構性的失業
摩擦性的失業
不是每個人可以這麼快轉換的
這社會很不公平
我希望我不只是一個分析師
我希望是個預言家
我真的希望能改變你的人生
可是對於投資股票的人
非常公平
你現在就Buy and hold
分散投資
你不懂你就買ETF
你過了
上10萬點你會愛我一輩子
我告訴你哪個分析師
我管你什麼00981A
00981A最爛的時候
我還說你可以買他
我管你什麼00981A賣什麼國巨
我告訴你 我不要說國巨
信昌電多少
禾伸堂多少
既生巨禾伸堂
禾伸堂創新高了
2492華新科也創新高了
我為什麼要執著於國巨
我只是要告訴你大象也會跳舞
我再給你預告
這3天內國巨隨時再噴一根
而且會大漲特漲
甚至只要行情不要太差 我告訴你
國巨會先漲停 為什麼
因為國巨是少數
你看 我剛才看到
華新科有沒有看到
都已經突破這邊了對不對 放大
都已經突破這邊了
我好喜歡現在這個畫面
有沒有 華新科都在這邊了
禾伸堂也在這邊
都突破前高了
突破前高這個地方
華新科 禾伸堂在這邊
國巨在這邊
人家是龍頭
我是要讓你知道
我是喊水會結凍的分析師
我全部會員要是去買禾伸堂 信昌電
早就鎖死了
塞我牙縫 塞我鼻孔都不夠
我當預言家 我是要幫助你
我告訴你
現在最可憐 最可悲
就是把錢放在銀行
那這個台灣股市這樣漲
你都沒有辦法收穫台積電員工
幫你努力工作賺來的錢
我跟你講 你們真的很幸福
你們要看懂我看到的未來
以後10年後很多癌症會改變
可是癌症改變 有些癌症改變
是你細胞分裂造成的問題
可是問題是
有些是你生活習慣不好
你的生活習慣要養好
不然就算癌症 治好你這個癌症
還是有下個癌症 好不好
壓力不要那麼大
不要把自己搞得那麼大
我還有看到什麼福華第三代
吃素了
也是不幸去世了
要像我 但是我不是要批評人家
我說大家
你們壓力再怎麼大
應該沒有我的壓力大
有時候一秒鐘
真的是幾千萬 幾億上下
扛太多人了
可是我都可以享受這個壓力
你一定可以的
做你喜歡的事情
不要亂用融資
就不會壓力那麼大
Buy and hold
很快10萬點就會到了
你相信我 好不好 來
我國巨賣飛 那是你的問題
你看一堆人謝謝我
你看 這個有講
謝謝哲哲給我信心
我的國巨從1150攤到580
今天全出掉 有沒有看到
記得我這邊打勾勾的帳號
很多詐騙集團很厲害
現在都用我
是在這邊打藍勾勾
不是 是這邊打勾勾
不是這邊打藍勾勾
藍勾勾不能移到裡面去
這叫P圖 知道嗎
這叫修圖 修圖都可以造假
你看國巨的人 你看他怎麼說
謝謝哲哲給我信心
這是網友講的
你自己看到留言
我國巨從1150
這不是我的會員攤到580
你就一直加碼 一直加碼
今天全出掉 看起來是賺錢
因為580成本 今天賺錢
可是我告訴你
Wifi你會不開心
因為國巨可能會漲到800元
你可以再賺30%的
你從1150元
你可以解套變成還賺30%的
你只賺一半
聽我一半都可以幸福了
可是你看 他一直攤平
我有沒有叫你要攤平
那我跟你講
我叫你All in就All in
我叫你重壓就重壓
不是叫你All in同一檔股票
我還跟你講風險
股市沒有一定的
這是比較驚悚的台詞
你不要只聽一半
然後最後怪我
我跟你講
如果你習慣去怪人家的
拜託不要看我的節目
賺錢也沒來謝謝我
賠錢就會怪我
這種拜託退出
我郭哲榮不需要這種粉絲
我有沒有預測能力你們自己知道
我跟別人不同
我孤芳自賞
沒有 現在100多萬粉絲
這一段時間公開
台灣所有你看到任何行業的人
講最多AI的
最了解AI的就是我而已
其他人真的不能跟我們比
哲哲自我要求太完美
壓力一定很大 辛苦了
所以為什麼我以前
我這20年來常常假日加班
我現在會減少假日工作量
所以很多人
有些人我看到說
哲哲你假日要不要錄影
可是我真的跟一般人不一樣
我是20年來都很高壓
這一年我真的有點累了
但是我還是很高壓式的要求自己
只是以前都求200%的自己
現在只要求大概100%
就是這樣的差別 好不好
哲哲我愛你 手上沒持股的實在可憐
是啊 我那時候有沒有講
助理有沒有圖
4萬 應該沒有圖了
我說什麼 台灣股市
可憐 可惜 可悲
有沒有 43000 可惜啊
是不是 現在可憐啊
是不是 48000 47000
5萬呢 可悲啊
可憐啊 可憐之人必有可恨之處
聽我一半
你知道為什麼我的名言
打動每一個人嗎
因為我知道你還有錢
老實說 我們再一次投票
你是不是褲襠裡面還有錢
投票 投票
讓你們看看人多好玩
所以我真的 我跟你講
就算我講AI 講10年會取代你
你們很多人還是會大難臨頭
才會說我講的是對的
可是沒有關係
我的想法是能救一個是一個
我跟你講這真的
你們是最幸福的年代
在轉換啦 AI是不是
可惜 可憐 可悲
即將5萬點要可悲
哲哲感謝你推薦國巨
而且我跟你講
我說國巨你不一定要買
它不一定漲比較多
我那時候是不是跟你講說華新科
所以我以買華新科啦
來看一下
看一下 我上禮拜五就通通賺錢了啦
這禮拜再多賺一根啦
看一下 看一下
恭喜 恭喜 恭喜
來 今天漲停有沒有看到
上禮拜五漲停 今天再漲停
幫我念一下
來 我們依依不捨的導播
好 9月7號禮拜一今天的簡訊
恭喜2492華新科
股價開高走高直接衝上漲停
我們多次買進
最高已經獲利18%
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
有沒有聽哲哲的話呢
有沒有聽哲哲的話 來
為什麼 很簡單
為什麼哲哲會這樣
我講得很簡單啊
因為你們看不懂AI啊
台灣股市三大利多 頭版新聞
那個利多反應 升息利多反應
不是 是這個AGI
因為我跟你講喔
我覺得網路上有一則講得很好玩
就是好像看起來很多人在討論AI
但是99%的人不知道AI多恐怖
的確你們 其實你們大部分人
你們還是不懂它多恐怖
我慢慢跟你講喔
我很不屑啊
我要是老投顧
你看我多厲害啊
我今天漲停板啊
CPO強講CPO PCB強講PCB
航運股強講航運股
你們要那種分析師
去找別家投顧 不要找我
拜託 我不喜歡當那種無聊的投顧
好無聊 我已經財富自由
我想做我想做的事情
我能救一個 能幫一個
走在路上說哲哲你改變我的人生
這是我聽到最開心的事
就這樣子啊 好不好
我講那麼快喔
你們可能覺得很快對不對
像我有大舌頭對不對
ㄣㄤ不分對不對
我現在跟ChatGPT講話
我都是用這種語速
他都聽得懂 都不會有錯誤
所以我現在
有時候我有時候念一下
就是公司的培訓分析師或怎麼樣
我就覺得跟他們講得有點累
有時候這樣
有時候講話比較傷人
可是真的我現在跟AI講
他都聽得懂我在講什麼
都跟得上我的語速
所以他進步很恐怖
就像我講的
我說他已經恐怖到什麼
你們要懂我的意思啊
我說真的AGI發生的時候
大家在討論是不是AGI
一般這樣成長速度 這樣算快
AGI產生後
這樣成長
人類的成長速度會這樣子
現在已經開始了
很恐怖啊
我跟你講啊 我慢慢跟你講
因為我怕你們聽不懂
我講比較深入淺出
我已經做得很深入淺出了 來
我現在跟你講 來 先講一件事
因為現在Threads有很多
假設我截圖對不對
有沒有看到
要進我群組添加管理Line
我跟你講 我的Line在這邊啊
畫面給我
我的Line在這邊
你要不要加隨便你
我不會叫你一定要加啦
還做圖片給你
做圖片給你叫你要加Line都是假的
你要不要加隨便啦
是你加我的Line
我才會告訴你啦
你怎麼樣 怎麼樣
你要不要加入我的會員啦
你不加我的Line
我沒有勉強你啦
我跟你講
我不缺錢 不缺會員 不缺粉絲
不好意思 三不缺
沒有辦法 我就跩
因為我就算醜的
很像醜什麼 像八兩金 像什麼樣
我不知道像誰
這樣好像人格污辱人家 算了
反正長得就是不好看 像蔡頭
人家都走了 算了 我愛他
長得很醜
我準就好了
像金城武 我不準也沒用啊
我不缺 我不缺 我不缺
好不好 我也不缺錢
好不好 OK
我現在就是感覺問題 好不好
就像同業一樣
亂攻擊我 感覺問題
我該回擊 回擊一輩子我都不在乎
砸1000萬 1億我都不在乎
我就是這種人
請敬告各個同業
不要在網路上
用一些什麼人頭戶
我都知道是哪一家投顧
算了 我不想講了
你們怎麼會覺得哲哲是傻瓜
好啦 這個是講給同業
而且把餅做大
我郭哲榮有把餅做大喔
你們現在賺的錢應該有比以前多
好不好 行情也不錯喔
好啦 扯遠了
好啦 我跟你講我不缺啦
所以我不會主動叫你要加會員
叫你要加LINE
這是假的 AI修改截圖
這是我的帳號沒錯
但是這不是我的對話
反正你只要看到有圖片
叫你加LINE就是假的
好不好 還有他在裡面
藍勾勾在這邊
他加在這裡面也是假的 好不好
反正叫你主動加LINE的就是假的
來 我跟你講
你看假的有多誇張
這個新聞有沒有看到
幸好我馬上跟大家講
不然今天很多人賣掉國巨 賣掉華新科
有新聞啦
郭哲榮太紅被盯上
假帳號突喊下週一賣光光
網友嚇喊差點信了
我看以前有個投顧
某個張姓分析師
暗示說我買廣告
笑死了 如果我買廣告
那我跟你講
有時候一天就8 9則新聞
我買廣告買到破產 你知道嗎
我根本不需要買廣告
廣告自己來找我好不好
你們要不要去搜尋一下郭哲榮的新聞
有些網友還講
我這是水軍
那我也太有錢吧
我這個要砸幾億
我們每天都一堆新聞 哪需要砸錢
郭哲榮太紅被盯上
假帳號突喊下週一賣光股票
網友嚇傻 差點信了
你看連這個人家冒充我
人家假冒我亂講話
都可以有一篇新聞
假日都可以有一篇新聞
你不找最紅的分析師
你要找菜鳥分析師 找誰
也不一定 菜鳥不一定不好
可是摩爾出身的分析師
在摩爾的分析師
我可以做品質保證
其他家我不會特別針對誰
但是我沒辦法做品質保證
就這麼簡單
你看連假帳號模仿我
亂喊下週一要賣光股票
都可以有一則新聞
你不找我找誰 OK嗎
來 這真的很誇張
好不好 記得一下
你要找找最紅的分析師
來 我看一下
現在要講AGI什麼
先講AGI是什麼
來看一下投票 夭壽
你看還有6成的人還有錢
還有6成的人還有錢 來看一下
你是不是還有錢 放大
你是不是還有錢
6成的人 這是60%
這是41%
59% 41%
居然還有6成的人還有錢
你也拜託一下
你還有錢 你還不加碼
你現在趕快買
一堆股票拉起來
你不要到時候像精材
我說精材的中實戶 大戶
一定有看我們的節目 很恐怖
他這種拉法
我是不是說拉上去就很恐怖了
你看這種漲法
從288到469
那個很誇張 漲個70%
是不是 差不多漲個70%
70%這沒幾天 這是精材
人生真的很精彩
有些網友你看喔
哲哲以前的股票都沒講 精材沒講
胡扯
太扯了
我是這種人嗎
人在做天在看
有些人根本就看我一半的節目
不要笑死
永遠講我以前的股票
你怎麼不講我今年
我讓人家賺了幾百%
沒關係 開心就好
反正哲哲現在不做最大
我想講什麼就講什麼
我不去在乎
偶爾會在乎 但我不想那麼在乎
你看這短短就70%了
誇不誇張
而且你看我今年
股票績效為什麼很誇張
最誇張的是我賺100%我都不走
精材一堆會員賺100% 一堆
等一下先講AGI
AGI比較重要
講那個績效
我績效好不好
我光是一個465.5的一個國巨
那附近 有沒有跌停板
你想買幾張就買幾張
只有我敢喊
買 叫你All in就All in
叫你重壓就重壓
全世界都嚇到了
我就不太懂
1220元的國巨跟400多元國巨
哪邊基本面有改變 你告訴我
哪邊基本面有改變 你就不理我
精材剛才唸過了沒
還沒嗎 唸一下
精材你看
你看我們最高已經賺140幾%了
我們一堆會員基本上都賺100%了
有買精材的
來唸一下 恭喜
好 9月7號禮拜一 今天的簡訊
恭喜3374精材
股價差點就漲停
再創歷史新高
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺142% 財富翻倍
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢了
精材漲停 有沒有看到
被動元件 華新科連2天漲停
有沒有看到
國巨也是一樣
是不是 今天也拉了最多7%
所以我今天
你不要什麼被動元件
我被動不被動
唱一下
愛你越久我越被動
好 化被動為主動
我今天主動88專案 好不好
主動聽我的訊息
你被動一下沒關係
我化被動為主動
行情好的時候讓你主動發發發
讓你發發發
主動88專案
你自己參考
因為今天入會電話爆掉了
我沒有關係 好不好
要不要參加 隨便你
我這一波救了好多國巨的人
我告訴你 你看你不攤平
你是不是早就差很多了
可是我告訴你有限度的攤平
我叫你不要超過50%
叫你不要融資借款
又沒叫你有壓力
你們都不照做
最傻的就是把錢放在銀行
你記得 好不好
AI時代
這個錢根本就是有點送你了
台灣就是要到10萬點了
我跟你講 好 你們不相信
我看到的是未來
剛才已經幾十個人見證了
2020年我是第一個公開講要買口罩
會缺貨
哪個人有這樣預測的能力啊
然後跟你講一年內會產生疫苗
你知道那時候講的時候被多少人罵
真的很誇張 有人來罵我
有醫生來罵我
然後呢 我不在乎啊
我現在比那時候更肯定啊
我那時候 你想想看喔
你們有經歷過就知道喔
然後你們奇怪
那時候一堆人
一開始有疫苗打 你們不緊張
等到疫情發生的時候
好不容易有疫苗了
然後台灣不是在封鎖嗎 全面封鎖嗎
那時候效果不錯
可是開始 我說遲早會缺疫苗的
你們不相信
等到要打疫苗的時候你們缺了
我跟你們講的時候都有時間打
你看黃仁勳講的話 來
這個恭喜喔
來 就是黃仁勳講的
只用了4年
英文是說在4年裡面啦
但是一樣意思啦
有沒有看到
他順便介紹自己的GPU啦
賣鏟子啦
什麼叫AGI
我上禮拜有秀這張圖片嘛 對不對
就是你可以數字推理 我們看左邊就好
2到6 3到12 4到20 那5呢
2推論到6 3到12 4到20
其實是什麼
2到6是乘以3
3到12是乘以4
所以這邊是乘以3 4 5 6
所以是5乘6等於30
這是一般智力測驗
以前他會答對
是因為他參考過去資料
現在就算他不參考過去資料
他也可以舉一反三
這叫AGI 超級AI
簡稱超級AI就知道
一般通用的
G就是General
通用的AI 知道嗎
通用的AI 什麼叫通用AI
AlphaGo以前在2012年代
我忘記什麼時候
那時候圍棋大師 韓國的圍棋大師
韓國的冠軍 世界冠軍跟他下棋
贏不了
AI時代來臨了
可是AlphaGo只會下圍棋
你叫他下象棋 他就不行了
現在不是 AGI是怎麼樣
我圍棋教你以後對不對
或者是不用教你
你看人家怎麼下棋以後
他就知道規則是什麼 很恐怖喔
然後象棋他看了以後知道什麼
通用的AI 舉一反三
像人類一樣
懂不懂 人類看一看象棋
他自然會學會啊 你懂不懂
人類看一看語言 他自然會講話啊
你知道那個
有些人說猴子啊 或者狗啊
怎麼學人類的語言 沒辦法
可是人類為什麼那麼聰明
他可以舉一反三
我聽一聽 你把小孩子
丟到一個語言的環境
就算不是他的母語
講一講話他還是久了會聽懂
他會舉一反三
這個人工智慧
一般的AI跟他最大差別是
以前沒有AGI 沒有超級AI
沒有一般的人工智慧 你懂不懂
AGI好不好
所以這個AGI 超級AI出現以後
不好意思 就像人類一樣
他可以思考了 他可以舉一反三了
那舉一反三怎麼樣 聽我這句話喔
舉一反三以後
你們以前資本支出怎麼樣
我投入錢嘛 資本支出
就是我投入錢
以前資本支出只能產出勞力
很難產出智力
這個智力 Excel或怎麼樣
還是要人力輔助 沒錯吧
還是要人的智力輔助
我以前再怎麼樣
我那個蒸汽機或怎麼樣
我不需要人力
但我還是需要人的智商
以後AGI的出現
不好意思 我投入資本
以前可以產出勞力 勞動力嘛
我不用去農田啊
去耕地啊 怎麼樣
耕地機啊 耕田的機器啊
以前的資本支出
投錢進去以後對不對
我投錢進去後 我產生的是勞力
現在是投錢進去後
投入資本後 我產生的是智力
而且從頭到尾幫我做好
這是很恐怖的 你知不知道
把我這一段多看幾次
沒有人跟你講這些
他們那些人 第一個
99%的人不懂什麼叫AGI
1%的人 如果真的有分析師懂
他也不在乎你
他只在乎我有沒有漲停板
我不屑
你要不要參加這個主動88專案
隨便你啊
要不要參加 反正我已經不缺會員了
我光是一個1億 我就賺1800萬
我想回饋社會
講回饋社會不是嘴巴講的好不好
你看我的節目內容就知道
我講了多久AI
我跟你講 你真的身邊有朋友
做一些助理的
你們要嘛就是改變行業
最好是改變行業 然後多用AI
你不改變行業沒關係 你要多用AI
你一天用不到AI用10題
你會被人家淘汰
真的 你一天問不到AI 10個問題
你記得我這句話
我拜託你們好不好 我拜託你們
AGI很恐怖 來
傳統的AI是單一領域
依賴指令 一次完成對不對
AGI 這比AI agent更厲害
AI agent叫你幫他做很多事情
所以以後可以AGI結合AI agent
你乾脆就叫AGI就好了
我可以跨領域理解
而且就算你沒有規則都沒關係
自主推理 執行多步驟任務 很恐怖
你懂不懂 以前我Excel
就是資本支出產出以後是Excel
沒有 現在你也不用問他Excel
他自己可以產出類似Excel的東西
你只要幫我分析財報就好
幫我做個圖表就好
你懂嗎 都是這樣子
譬如說像我們公司的流程
沒關係 我公司員工聽到
也是希望他們多用AI
在3到5年內會很恐怖
我們是不好意思 要填表單
填表單以後 要加入這個會員
要加入郭哲榮分析師
加入某個分析師
江江老師 基鼎老師 鈺凱老師
Eason老師 育華
這些優秀的老師
加了以後 填了以後我們再開啟簡訊
然後3個月期的
普通會員的 特別會員的
每個會員等級 可能每個人等級不同
然後分得很細
以前要寫程式很麻煩
所以我們需要很多人力
以後基本上我只要跟他講
我們有什麼等級會員
這個老師有什麼等級會員
他要加這個等級會員以後
怎麼直接開通
然後怎麼算業績
基本上你只要講清楚
我們的公司的工作的邏輯
一天就全部都達成了
然後以後我們要填入會資料
以前要填入會資料
可能要花幾十個小時
因為假設有十個人
一個人花3個小時 花3 4個小時
以後不用 3分鐘全部跑完
那這些人怎麼辦
公司的這些人怎麼辦
我不是危言聳聽 這是未來趨勢
不是我要淘汰他們 而是社會的趨勢
我也沒說現在要淘汰
可是已經越來越恐怖了
我講的不只是我們公司的問題
我們公司可以解決很多流程
很多行業
現在什麼設計師行業
Blender 設計模型的那個程式
我也看了一下
我就是什麼都喜歡沾一點
他們也是覺得很恐怖
你拍幾張照片 就一個Blender 3D模型建模
以前建模要好幾天
現在幾分鐘就好了
只要你願意花錢
這個很恐怖 設計影片也是一樣
剪輯影片也是一樣
所以導播你們都一定要去學 很恐怖
你們只是看不懂我看到的未來
沒關係 你就每天聽我講就好
會很多人失業
可是也很多人會很幸福
差別在你願不願意去學習AI
你願不願意去接納AI
接納AI的股票 接納AI
你會比那些智商很高
但是個性很固執的人來得成功
出社會後
為什麼很多高學歷的人
出社會後不一定成功
為什麼就成功那些人
因為出社會後
決定你成功的
不是你的智商 而是你的智慧
擁抱AI是決定你
是不是有智慧的人
記住我這句話
一定要記住我這句話
我真的是喜歡當預言家
你看一個頂尖工程師
假設年薪1000萬
我公司本來1000位
1000萬也是很有可能的
你看中華電信都2 300萬是不是
很多2 300萬的工程師
美國都怎麼樣
每年 假設就200萬就好了
那每年是20億的資本支出
我就算投資幾億
買個10億元的算力成本又怎麼樣
我還是划算
所以就像我講的
以前資本支出 就是我投錢進去
只能轉換成勞力
現在可以直接轉換成智力
我不需要再找一個人
然後再幫我做
就算以前我想生出來的軟體
我還是要一個人輔助
現在基本上不用了
十幾個人裡面我只要找一個人就好了
稍微監視他一下 監督他一下
全球有數十兆美元的人類薪資市場
一年喔 數十兆
我只要 假設我3%
我可能省了兩兆的資本支出市場
兩兆的薪資市場
我問你喔
數十兆我只要2%的人被取代
我覺得不只2%的人被取代
我問你大家
2%的人被取代對不對
數十兆的勞力薪資
我一年就算資本支出7500億美元
又怎麼樣
所以你們看到的是泡沫
我看到的是你們在胡扯
就只會看財報有什麼用
沒有想像力 現在比AI都不如
華爾街那些分析師都要被取代
沒辦法 沒有想像力的人都要被取代
我沒算資本支出
AI泡沫 AI變現
對 7500億我借錢
現金流為負
笑死人 我還舉2008年一樣
給我算什麼鴻海 台積電
一堆財經台給我算
鴻海 台積電資本支出
營運現金流是為負的
我快笑死了
不是一樣的笑話嗎
算7500億會不會賺到錢
你們看不到未來嘛
那你去想想看
哲哲都想到 那些人
那些亞馬遜 Google
微軟 臉書的CEO
智商會比我低嗎
他們是最一線的人
都知道這些未來的趨勢
這個未來很現實
很多人覺得很殘酷
可是你知道我有時候覺得
有些人不知道該怎麼說
他又想要薪水高
又想要很簡單的人生
怎麼可能
有 有一個最簡單的事情 投資
投資真的很簡單
有時候不要想太多
想太多還賠錢
真的 工作沒有辦法
你看這些人比你努力又認真
這些CEO比你有錢
到現在還在比你認真
這個看一下
你怎麼會覺得他們是傻瓜
花那麼多資本支出是傻瓜
不算AI泡沫 這樣懂嗎
這個7500億又怎麼樣
以後可以省幾兆美金
所以他們資本支出
我認為以後都有回報
記住我這句話好不好
當前是應該40兆美債攤還的趨勢
如果能省人力成本 通膨還會是通膨嗎
原油可以大量產出 通膨還是通膨嗎
那通膨不是通膨的話 40兆美債
如果降息以後 40兆美債
會不會情況比較好
你要懂我在說什麼
所以解決通膨最好的
是機器人化 是不是
所以機器人這個東西
我以前說要10年 我看現在不用了
可以快速的
環球晶跟中美晶
當然什麼都會缺
記憶體不會缺喔
矽晶圓 先進製程不會缺喔
都是會缺 好不好
愛哲哲 謝謝大家 好不好
說AI是泡沫想撿便宜
沒有 大部分人是不懂
真的 大部分人是不懂
你看你跟我講
哪一個分析師像我講AI 講AGI
講這些AI講那麼清楚
我在去年26000的時候
我就告訴你那個Gemini好厲害
在ChatGPT之前
你看我那時候講的名言
在Gemini
Google的Gemini面前
ChatGPT是垃圾
ChatGPT是第一代的AI
2023年 因為他公布了AI的程式
ChatGPT 讓台灣股市
從1萬多點一路漲到快5萬點
可是那時候我說Gemini好恐怖
Gemini已經取代ChatGPT了
可是我現在怎麼樣
我這幾個月跟你講
在ChatGPT面前 變了 立場互換了
在ChatGPT面前 Gemini是垃圾
他除了畫圖比較厲害以外
你們有在比較就知道了
那就代表 你看是不是一代 一代
一代 一代 不要聽錯
一代 一代的怎麼樣
沒事 沒事
一代 一代的更新的速度越來越快
很恐怖 就是我講的
你覺得AI的發展
精材是這樣漲嘛
一般這樣漲就很誇張了
精材是這樣漲
AI發展的速度是這樣子
基本上90度
我還畫太斜了
應該要畫這樣才對
不會回到過去啦 畫那麼誇張
AI就發展速度這麼快
我跟你講通常那些科技業真正的大老闆
都懂我在說什麼
是大家不太懂 好不好
我再跟大家講
來 一代 一代
不是喔 不是這樣喔
微星就說不要去追嘛
你這邊有一堆低價的國巨在怕什麼
國巨為什麼會這樣漲不上去
遲早會漲 為什麼
在洗籌碼 50萬散戶耶
我扛50萬散戶
我忍者龜扛50萬散戶 扛很重耶
一定有人賺一堆錢就走了
你看啊 今天怎麼講
哲哲謝謝你喔
所以國巨為什麼漲不上去
因為先把那些人洗掉嘛 你知道嗎
來 先把這些人洗掉
謝謝哲哲給我信心
我國巨從1150元
攤到580 今天全出了
他明明可以賺更多
他們只是想賺就跑 散戶嘛
所以可能有幾十萬的人想要這樣走
就讓他走 走光光以後他們後悔
再追第二次啦
那時候他們就是我們的買盤了
就謝謝他們 好不好
我就喜歡選最高難度的
就讓我選經濟日報 參加比賽
我要就是突破紀錄 一直突破紀錄
好不好 微星好可憐
微星叫可憐 那拜託你不要看我節目
微星可憐什麼東西啊
那國巨才叫可憐 微星哪邊可憐
這種走勢叫可憐 你也拜託一下
看那麼短不要來參加
看這麼短 不要當我的粉絲
會員也不要勉強 拜託
好不好 你們要那種不正當的預期
投資有賺有賠 我每次都跟很多人講
不勉強 好不好
你要老實的找我
你要每天漲停板 詐騙集團 神棍
一堆有
股神的存在 股市之神
你慢慢找 好不好
神棍 詐騙集團很多 你自己可以找
OK嗎 好不好
我要是別的老師
我今天要講精材 講國巨 講華新科
我講個半小時就好了
我還跟你扯AGI幹嘛
跟我收會員什麼關係
你要懂我的用心良苦 好不好
哲哲可以刺激一下中美晶嗎
隨時會噴你 不要擔心
中美晶我還不敢講
6488環球晶我比較有信心
3532 其實台勝科你看不出來也很強嗎
台勝科都快噴了 有沒有看到
他已經蠢蠢欲動了 有沒有
台勝科我想再加碼
助理提醒我一下
OK 提醒我一下
明天就要噴 國巨跟環球晶OK嗎
要噴了 好不好
環球晶1000附近是不是壓力很大
你管他壓力大不大
精材之前也有一堆壓力
你管他壓力大不大 好不好
哲哲投資長能不能提攜一下日電貿
不用提攜了嘛
你被動元件到最後都一起起漲好不好
哲哲可不可以華邦電送暖
可以 記憶體OK
記憶體最大問題只是漲太多
不然其實還OK
華邦電看起來有機會噴出去 好不好
8299群聯也有機會
好不好 OK嗎
8299群聯 等一下
群聯也有機會 那還有什麼股票
鴻海 講一下
不要刺激哲哲
哲哲不開心就會封鎖帳號 為什麼
因為我不缺錢 我不缺粉絲 好不好
人開心最重要
你賺錢的目的不就是自由嗎
對 我就自由 OK嗎
所以不要刺激我
刺激我 哲哲你怎麼不講
不好意思 我們下輩子再聯絡
就不要參加我的粉絲
不要參加我的會員
不要勉強自己啦
我跩 問題是我很用心對待大家
我不會跩 我是對那種
對我有不正確期待的人
我會很生氣 這樣懂嗎
來 世界先進看起來要噴了
世界先進根本就莫名其妙
所以你們還有錢
你們買一些還在地板上的股票
微星為什麼今天你覺得可憐
我覺得最好笑
微星是現在高價股就不要追
就像精材 我現在也不敢買
我就放著
我說老實話 我不敢叫人家加碼
因為我不知道裡面的大戶什麼時候
因為這裡明顯有大戶
看起來是好的大戶
我不知道他要把你拉到什麼地方
我覺得看起來一副就是
拉到1000塊都有可能
哲哲1000塊喔 現在400多 有可能
我不會像環球晶這麼稍微肯定
肯定不代表百分之百
我不會像環球晶這麼肯定
但是看起來一副就是要衝個7 800元
就放著就好了
精材我以前被人家罵很久
我不在乎 好不好
3035智原 如果你覺得智原爛 慢
你就換嘛
我也考慮要換
我一些股票要開始慢慢發動
要換股票
要提醒我 好不好
我再跟你一一說明
不是導播 對不起 助理啦
太多疊字了
助理到時候我們再開會
有些比如說智原 不能講
或者有些股票
大家在成本附近
這個我們自己會員調整
成本附近想要換的 我會給他換一下
鴻海可能會換
沒有筆 眉筆
這都是會員權益好不好
還有什麼
沒什麼 真的沒什麼
該講的都講了
對 講個笑話 來看一下
你看有人講說
剛才看到有人假冒哲哲
原本想檢舉有沒有看到
結果他的影片
大概差不多發現了30個郭哲榮
照片裡面有藍勾勾
我真的佩服詐騙集團的創意
我看他應該有看我的節目 受不了
那一天我念他們
說你們不要太誇張
我本來根本不想管他們
問題是你一天
100個假冒帳號我能受得了嗎
腳都騎到我頭上了 是不是
跟他說假冒帳號 還一直罵我
詐騙集團靠我吃穿還罵我
導播你不覺得很誇張嗎
你一天大概刪除幾個
我一天刪除快100個了 你大概幾個
4 50個有
一天真的很誇張
所以他搜尋一下郭哲榮分析師
隨便搜尋就3 40個
這是畫面而已 他是影片
我只是截圖而已
然後我就開玩笑說 來
我是郭哲榮模仿大賽的第101名
我看模仿郭哲榮 他們比我厲害
可是我是真的 好不好
要看帳號旁邊有藍勾勾
不是照片裡面有
照片裡面的藍勾勾是假的好不好
有沒有看到 是帳號旁邊有藍勾勾
帳號有沒有看到 這是帳號
不是在這邊
在這邊都是P圖 修圖 那都是假的
現在圖片 最不可信的就是圖片
以後不可信的是影片 好不好
這樣很好啦
假設你們以後被偷拍
死不承認說這是假的
那不是我 那是影片P的
反正以後根本看不出來 好不好
這是唯一的幸福吧
好啦 來 s178
我也不懂有些人怎麼會想偷拍影片
奇怪 我不太懂那些東西
還有醫美機構
看那些到底要幹嘛 我也不太懂
會比較開心嗎
我覺得心裡有點變態 真的
好啦 s178178 打勾勾
為什麼突然講這個東西 對
以後有影片被假冒
其實很多可能都假的
圖片也是最不可信的
s178178 打勾勾這邊
這是Threads的帳號 跟IG的帳號
打勾勾在這邊 不能在這邊
在這邊你看 一堆仿冒有沒有
在這邊有沒有看到
都在這邊有沒有看到 很扯
是要在這邊打勾勾
所以你看他們這邊假的
全部都沒有在這邊打勾勾 有沒有看到
在這邊打勾勾是錯的
這邊打勾勾 知不知道 好累
我是郭哲榮模仿大賽
哲哲模仿大賽 第101名
因為其他的模仿我太厲害了
還語氣學我 OK嗎
這個笑話讓大家笑一下
來 詐騙可惡都要鞭刑吧
要看主管機關 看立委們
你是不是還有錢
57% 結束了對不對
178身高 哲哲差不多啦
就是這個身高 來
笑死
裡面有藍勾勾真的很扯
虧他們想得出來
對啊 我也很佩服他們 好不好
矽力打氣一下
我不要 我光國巨就很累了
有些分析師影片是AI假造的
YT上看到哲哲的影片
Threads還會推假帳號給你
所以我最討厭的就是臉書
其實Threads滿好用的 我就用了 來
好 來 矽力
哲哲57%人還有錢怎麼看
我能說什麼 我要說活該嗎
這就是你的人生選擇
反正我告訴你
反正等到國巨800元 1000元以上
你會氣你自己
不用我懲罰你
你自己會氣自己 那就夠了
好不好 OK嗎
哲哲比彭于晏還多了 多什麼
沒有啦 人家比較帥
哲哲新日興怎麼看
新日興不錯 但它不是AI
它是摺疊手機
如果今天台灣股市沒有AI題材
我會說你要買新日興
有AI題材就買了 好不好
就不一定要買新日興了好不好
華邦電還會往上嗎 有機會
華邦電我逢低 我還是有在買好不好
還有一檔股票 你看一下
現在幾分了
43 44 好啦 來啦
聯發科 我有沒有說我要買聯發科
有吧 我4000多元賣掉
我再買回來 為什麼
不一樣 跟麥格理邏輯不一樣
那是因為輝達有投資它
光是輝達有投資它就不一樣了
黃仁勳看得比較遠
豬站在風口上也會飛
風口在哪邊
風口在黃仁勳吹的風上面
我就是那個豬
我站上去就可以飛了
就這麼簡單而已
黃仁勳支持它 我就買
你們為什麼要想那麼複雜
不知道就買台積電
更不知道又怕風險
就買台灣50
一半是台積電的形狀
但是又可以分散風險
想要刺激找我
你看一個精材140幾%
我跟你講精材也好
我記得我沒有錯的話
助理記得一件事 幫我算一下
我記得我1600的時候的環球晶
大概賺170%
沒走 眼睜睜看它1600跌到800元
I don't care
一堆會員精材加碼
國巨下去
上去不關我的事情
我早就獲利走掉
下去我開心每天加碼
你告訴我光是國巨這一役
誰敢這麼有Guts喊 誰啦
每個分析師都避之唯恐不及
之前不是有講記憶體 被動元件
跌下去都不關他的事
你看我CPO很強 你看我航運股很強
不是這樣搞
分析師會被用臭
真的哲哲有把分析師這個門面
有把它用好一點
不是每天要講賺錢的
賠就賠 為什麼不敢講
有什麼好不敢講的
賺就賺 是不是
再不然就是有人冤枉我
說我的國巨600多元
我什麼時候買600多元
不要開玩笑了好不好
恭喜2327國巨股價開高
大漲7%多
再戰近期新高 準備
我們多次買進 最高已經獲利19%
我再講一次
再給你看一次 國巨隨時噴出
3天內我認為有機會碰到漲停板
不要說我沒說
只要信昌電
既生巨禾伸堂 禾伸堂再漲
他非常有機會 你看這邊
最高多少 這邊 600幾
我看一下
668 導播幫我記一下
最高是668這一波
668元 來 我們放大
所以668那很簡單
就一根漲停板多了 是不是
所以你看 很多股票
那不要放大好了
沒關係 再遠一點
這樣放大 OK了
668 你看這邊
很多股票在這邊 你自己看
這是華新科 禾伸堂都在這邊
國巨在這邊
隨時會補上
華新科 禾伸堂再往上的時候
他不得不 國巨不得不噴出去
一定有當沖大戶 隔日沖敢買
記得我這句話
因為一根的漲停
就是他們可以賺的價差
隔日沖也好
不要說一根漲停 賺個3%都划算
所以國巨隨時會有一根漲停板
我認為這個禮拜就有機會
我再重複講一下
這個禮拜好了
這個禮拜隨時會再一根漲停板
只要行情不要太差
只要禾伸堂 華新科拉上去
他們拉也不用太多
拉個3 5%就可以了
就讓你看到什麼叫真正的老大
什麼叫真正老大 我
什麼叫被動元件老大 國巨
記得一件事情
股票就是買低賣高
這是廢話 我做給你看
懂不懂
叫你All in就All in
叫你重壓就重壓
我真的是跟大家講
我今天講個名言
曾經有一批便宜的被動元件
國巨 華新科在我面前
我居然沒有珍惜他
眼看他漲上去了
如果再給我一次機會
我會對他說一句話
我叫你All in就All in
我叫你重壓就重壓
然後有人說這個是周星馳的梗
在哪邊 這是什麼梗
這是大話西遊是不是
然後居然沒有人聽懂這個梗
還有網友說什麼
那我就說
那我應該改個BLACKPINK的歌詞
國巨
他有什麼歌詞 in area
還有什麼歌詞
還有Big Bang的歌詞
有人叫我改Big Bang
我不要改Big Bang的歌詞
你知道為什麼嗎
Bang Bang Bang 股票還變不見
Bang Bang Bang 漲停變不見
有冷嗎 好笑的話請留言
可是你有看到我的笑話
不是抄網路的
我絕不抄網路的 太無聊了
太無聊 我不喜歡背網路笑話
所以有些人會背網路笑話
有些人背網路笑話 背得不錯
我不喜歡背 好不好
Bang Bang Bang 股票變不見
漲停變不見
叫你All in就All in
周星哲 笑死人
All in啦 好不好
這個笑話
還有剛才Bang Bang Bang的
希望送給Big Bang的粉絲
10月9號有沒有
大家有沒有
Big Bang演唱會門票有沒有搶到
戴耳機真的嚇到
有心情講脫口秀嗎
脫口秀 我要寫台詞我很強啦
太忙了啦
我喜歡是頭腦賺錢
脫口秀我也會講
我也會寫 背台詞
我不太喜歡背台詞
我喜歡臨時反應
脫口秀都準備台詞了
但是他們也算很厲害
只是我更厲害的是預測未來
跟一般脫口秀比的話
說不定就是伯仲之間
跟很厲害的脫口秀
可是如果要比的是智慧
看到未來的能力
那我應該頂尖
所以我還是適合當分析師 OK嗎
投資長怎麼看威剛
沒時間看威剛 夭壽
來 剩幾分鐘
50要結束了 來
主動 化被動原件
化被動為主動
主動88專案
你自己參考好不好
今天第一天
不知道什麼時候會結束
今天有點人多
好不好 隨時都會結束
你看一下國巨
50了是不是
國巨你看一下 連2天有沒有
上禮拜五 今天
國巨最高已經獲利19%
還不多喔
你趕快 你不要到時候我拉開成本
我問你 假設現在是精材
我賺142%
我怎麼叫你買
我賺142%我怎麼叫你加碼
我沒辦法加碼
我加碼 你又說我給你出貨
你會覺得我叫你幫我舊會員抬轎
不敢買精材 我賺100多%
新會員不敢買了
我不會叫新會員
基本上我不會叫新會員
難說 但是我不敢
理論上不會
華新科都剛賺錢而已
華新科賺18%
國巨最多賺19%
這些都剛賺錢 賺20%不多
你不要等到賺40% 50%
你問我要不要加碼
我很尷尬
聯發科也是剛買而已
聯發科之前賺了很多
賺100%以上 賺很多
但是現在第二次的聯發科再進場
這個剛賺而已
這個賺不到10%
這個你要來找我
所以你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
今天這個Bang Bang Bang
台灣股市Bang漲停 來
化被動為主動
主動88專案
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
叫你All in就All in
叫你重壓就重壓
你有沒有聽哲哲的話
化被動為主動
主動88專案
趕快把握住
台灣股市我跟你講
10萬點不是夢
因為超級AI已經來臨了
而這一切的一切哲哲預告在前面
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
我愛你們 Byebye